Why is that we bother doing anything?
Why is it that we work our whole life building
and creating things beyond the necessary minimum?
Developing careers and businesses.
Innovating technologies.
And making art.
All things that we work so hard for, just
to end up saying goodbye forever to them when
we pass on.
The reason why it might seem foolish to bother
working towards creating anything, is the
same reason why we do: the awareness of death.
As a creature that can ponder and foresee
the imminence of its own mortality, we are
compelled to not only survive the here and
now, but to extend our existence beyond the
limited timeline of our perishable mind and
body.
Because of death, we find great fulfillment
in the process of bringing things from within
our self, outside of our self.
Manifesting things into reality that would
not exist if it were not for our sole existence.
Because it is this process that makes us feel
like we can beat death.
That we can somehow live beyond it.
That our existence can have meaning in spite
of it.
During our short lifetime, we want nothing
more than to leave our individual fingerprint
on reality.
To create a ripple that floods into the eternal.
Because the concept of accomplishing this
is what allows us to truly tolerate the foresight
of our own death.
It is what gives us the hope that we are connected
to the infinite.
And it is this that we should pursue.
Do that which fulfills this and makes you
feel, even if just momentarily, like you are
god.
Do what is unique to you.
What is innovative and impactful.
Say the unsaid.
Do the undone.
Bring your thoughts, ideas, and sense of life
into reality.
Do something that can live on in your name.
Because it just might, and that’s a pretty
cool reason to bother doing anything.